thank you to private internet access for
sponsoring today's episode Pia provides
a secure reliable VPN connection click
the link in the description below to
receive 82 off the first two years plus
four months of free service
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Journey to the microcosmos headquarters
have been very excited about this
ciliate which is called a legendrea
lawyers a James our master of
microscopes found it in a lake which
made him just one of five people in
human history who had ever found this
organism in our last episode we talked
about how his discoveries managed to
reconcile the contradictions that had
gone unexplained in the observations of
previous scientists had made what we
didn't talk about was the fact that
James and his collaborators Dr Dimitra
andreo and Professor Hanover F Esteban
were the first people to gather genetic
data about the legendread genus thanks
in part to their legendre Eloise friends
now when we say genetic data we could be
referring to a lot of different things
in part because genes are such an
extensive varied landscape that humans
are only in the early days of being able
to describe genes contains instructions
that tell ourselves how to make the
proteins that carry out our lives as
they drive chemical reactions or produce
key structures or pass along information
and those instructions are written in
the language of DNA a molecular double
helix whose components spell out
individual bits of a message like
letters building up into a word that
builds up into a manual for life to make
that language comprehensible to us
scientists use the letters a t g and C
to represent the chemical bases that
link together to form that code but
within every living organism whether it
is us or the organisms we are watching
that code is a living churning evolving
force that enshrines our identity in
relation to so many others in our
journey through the microcosmos we have
often seen the way genetic material and
the use of phylogenetic techniques
reveal new ways to see an org organism's
Identity or to upend a set of
relationships we thought existed in the
microcosmos like when scientists
realized that the organisms they had
gathered together in the taxonomic group
of amoeba were not really so closely
related after all the idea is simple
let's compare organisms and see if we
can figure out based on their
similarities and differences how closely
related they are we can and have done
this with microscopes and extensive
descriptions of what different microbes
look like and act like but like we said
genetics has often upended what we have
gleaned just through observation but to
study organisms at the genetic level we
need their DNA which means that we need
to be able to Wade through all the bits
and pieces lying within their tiny
bodies to pick out something even tinier
something that we cannot just dig out
with a shovel so how how does James
manage to get the precious DNA from
legendre Eloise and other ciliates he is
interested in studying
starts by grabbing the organism
separating it from the crowd in a manner
similar to what you can see him doing
here with some other microbes there they
are just chilling until James appears
with a tool called a micropipette and
draws them right up after taking the
silly that he's interested in it's time
for James to give it a little bath to
make sure that it's clean and remove any
other organisms that might Cloud up the
results he starts by squirting the
organism into a clean drop of water and
letting it swim around for a while then
grabbing a new clean micropipet James
repeats that process again and again and
again and again each time using a new
clean micropipet to draw the organism
into a fresh clean drop of water the
goal is to get that ciliate very very
clean and that means James sometimes has
to leave them swimming for as long as 30
minutes in that drop of water and that's
not just just to scrub their outsides
the insides need to be empty of any
ciliates they might have eaten that are
now taking up residence inside of a food
vacuole yes even a master of microscopes
has to wait around a bit for a cilia to
poop sometimes when he's done and the
ciliates are all cleaned up James
freezes them in a tiny tube getting them
ready for the next step isolating the
DNA the process is pretty simple he
takes the tube out of the freezer and
lets it thaw out and then he puts it
back into the freezer and lets it ice up
again just like the washing this is a
repetitive process over and over again
the organism is Frozen then thawed
frozen then thawed
each time that happens the cell changes
a little bit ice pierces through the
membrane and the insides of the cell
begin to disintegrate buried in the
cellular soup that remains is the
organism's DNA now separating that DNA
requires a technique that you have
probably heard a lot about in the past
few years PCR which stands for
polymerase Chain Reaction the goal of
PCR is to take a very small amount of
DNA and then make many many more copies
of it during the pandemic we relied on
PCR to find fragments of viral RNA in
our mucus and then amplify it so that
those small quantities of genetic
material could be detectable but PCR is
so important that even describing it as
a tool to save lives during a pandemic
feels like we are very much underselling
it it is one of the tools the premise is
so simple that it can be used and
adapted for any number of applications
since its Discovery in 1985 PCR has been
fundamental to the work of scientists
who are doing everything from hunting
down proteins to engineering new
technologies to creating new medical
therapies for today though pcr's main
use is to gather small segments of the
legend rail lawyers A's DNA that can
then be used to find where it belongs
taxonomically and as with the previous
steps that James had to undertake there
is a lot of repetition the ciliate that
was cleaned over and over again and then
Frozen and thawed over and over again
will now have its contents heated and
cooled in a mixture that will tear apart
the strands of DNA and find the part
that James wants to amplify over and
over again with each repetition the
number of DNA fragments goes up
exponentially so that in the end James
is holding a tube full of them ready to
be sent off so that a machine can
determine its sequence of A's T's C's
and G's for scientists to study further
with his prized DNA James was able to
find a family for the legendary eloyage
the family is Bethel today order
abdorada he was even able to find a
sibling episodium a papilliferum they
even have similar protruding structures
making their family resemblance
apparently beyond the genetic
similarities this is a relationship that
the early observers of legendre Eloise
might not have been able to infer and
even if they did the tools to verify
them didn't exist each time we visit the
microcosmos it is with knowledge and
tools that we did not have before that
is why it matters to discover again what
some someone found once before to dig
through old texts and familiar ponds
because buried deep within there is
always something unknown remaining to be
found
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
and thank you again to private internet
access for sponsoring today's episode
Dia provides a secure reliable VPN
connection but you might be asking
yourself what is a VPN well a VPN is a
virtual private Network that encrypts
your internet data hides your IP address
keeping your information secure and
protected but it also allows you to
watch streaming content that might not
be available in your area pia has a
next-gen server infrastructure covering
over 83 countries and in each and every
U.S state let's say you're in the mood
to Cozy up with some hot cocoa sit by
the fire and watch the classic film
white Christmas well if you're in the US
that's as simple as loading up Netflix
and typing in White Christmas but if you
are outside the US you will not find
white Christmas when you search for it
but thanks to Pia you won't have to miss
out on a Christmas classic because you
can access Us exclusive content no
matter where you are private internet
success works with all major streaming
services so you have access to all your
favorite content everywhere in the world
and Via is available for all platforms
and one subscription protects up to 10
devices at the same time you have a
30-day money-back guarantee if you don't
like the product or if it doesn't meet
your expectations and right now Pia VPN
is offering microcosmos viewers their
best deal yet an 82 discount and four
free months when you use the link Pia
vpn.com microcosmos
the names on the screen right now they
are the people who allow us to make
Journey to the micro Cosmos and to
continue diving deeper into our world
how we understand it the work that
people have done throughout history and
the work that is being done right now we
are so grateful to all of you if you
would like to join them and become one
of the reasons why we can do this you
can go to patreon.com
journey to micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
Weiss and look why wouldn't you you can
check out jam and germs on Instagram and
if you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
foreign
[Music]